[music]
>> I'm amazed for the first year of this
event that you got such a strong
turnout.
>> It's [music] a great group of people
that you have coordinated here to talk
about physical AI and robots. I mean, I
[music] haven't seen this done quite
this way at other conferences. So, great
lineup.
>> It's different than other similar events
I've been through because it's much more
deep. You see who came here. It's the
CTOs of the companies. It's the
executive level that has deep
understanding in what's going on right
now and what the needs are. [music] And
the conversation are extremely
professional here.
>> [music]
>> I think the coolest thing about robots
is their potential to impact human
lives. The goal of technology should be
to improve the way we live and work, and
I don't think there's any technology
that will have a bigger impact on human
life than robots. We're in the early
days for that. I think it'll be exciting
to watch this industry over the next 10
years.
>> [music]
>> I think it was much better than I
expected. Makina Summit, it's the place
to be.
>> [music]